today's episode is brought to you by
square cash hello square cash is the
best it's the best way to pay people
back period friends family lizards
munchkins ghosts anyone among the living
or dead I mean you know it can really
pay you back who are dead but you know
what I mean if they were alive they
should have Square cash setting or
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into the bank account in
seconds that's like this fast that's
like that fast
download the free square cash app for
iOS and Android now ever sowed 21 my
babies how did we do it how do we get
here if you hear my voice I was sick
about a week and a half ago I remember
you remember in the last episode and and
and and I was sick and it it's settled
after I was better and now I'm I
was going and then I had five shows and
it left it was like you know what SIA
the Nara it went like that and it's
gone I keep having to clear my throat
because all this stuff it's super
annoying but really cool that I'm
telling you guys this because I'm sure
it makes it really rootin for good
podcasting but I'm in New York I'm on
the road and I have no uhm producer with
me so I turned the air off in my hotel
room so you wouldn't hear it it's
already blistering hot cuz in New York
it's too hot and you notice cuz it's
just it's too humid all right Hoss fine
humans not let's wrap that up let's wrap
it all up let's not be human so you're
gonna hear some oh not be human or humid
not be humid um so a rainstorm started
and I'm starting to doing this podcast
so anyway
which is gone I think I sound a little
bit sexy and raspy but when I hit the
high notes uh ah look at that that's
awful if that's awful
I can't do that Luther Vandross so
yeah so I'm in New York City let's see
what happens so far I went to Baltimore
which I never wanted to go to really
except for the fact that now I have uh
there's a theater there that was awesome
man it was called the soundstage and I
had two shows it was great
I got like 25 to 30 minutes that's new
not for a man on fire um so I'm working
on that and I'm still trying doing some
of the men out fire stuff so that comes
out in my special comes out in the
Netflix in like seven days so I'm gonna
have to get this new material poppin so
I did two shows in Baltimore which were
great um shout-out to kid in the front
row what the hell was his name dammit I
already don't remember he was a 16 year
old kid which I was like how the
did he get in but his dad was there um I
can't remember his name but he was cool
I actually brought him up onstage to
hold the microphone while I tied my shoe
and he was a real good sport about it
sorry I forget a name bro but you were
super cool um
and then I went to Atlantic City and I
did the show in Atlantic City at the
Borgata bugatta which was awesome I
loved playing there it's a casino and in
casinos you see the dregs of the earth
so that's cool I don't know why but
every time I go to casino I see somebody
with one arm I don't know what the
that's all about and none wrong with
well there's a lot wrong with having one
arm you can't do a lot of things that
you should be able to do but um not
trying to down get down on anybody who
has one arm but there's always somebody
with one arm at a casino and I guess
that's because you only need one one arm
to pull the lever on the the
are called the slots yeah so I did
that
I got the out of there because
Atlantic City I mean just casinos are
not my thing and then went to Long
Island where I played in Huntington and
that was awesome um great shows had a
heckler at the second show this
idiot that uh kept calling out
this lady who came to be known as during
the show as an accountant and she was so
drunk and Long Island's like one of
those places like there were a thousand
people at the show and there was
definitely like a client of hers there
but she didn't go up saying
guess is getting these dick tonight
because she was with a dude and I was
like you're an accountant hey you're a
accountant don't be like that
period but also the accountant you do
that either worst accountant okay oh my
throat man I should be taking it easy
because I got shows in Florida but um
hmm I've got to do this guy back up this
Brinks truck dude I mean Jesus
Christ I got a what do you think the
podcast stops because my voice is gone
now I got to back up the Brinks
truck I'm gonna make sure Dunbar and
Brinks are reversing into my
garage I want to thank everybody for
listening last week's episode got the
most downloads and let's keep this
goin man because it really makes me want
to do more podcasts you know what I'll
tell you what if we get more and more
downloads I could do twice a week I
would do that I just want to make sure
that everybody wants that oh so yeah um
I'm coming up on Florida West Palm Beach
I'll be doing that um get your tickets
at Chris D'Elia calm and that's that
then I got Austin coming up and and on
and some other ones Albuquerque who
lives in hey got question for people now
Albuquerque who lives now Albuquerque
hey you live in Albuquerque
Varya real quick Gloria now it's free
conch you can live wherever you want but
if you live in Albuquerque Aryeh that's
that's the thing I want to know because
you know snoo max what what goes on in
New Mexicans live wherever you want but
if you live in albuquerque new max who
are you i hope that somebody tune into
my podcast right there for the first
time ever and heard that sentence and
thought oh this is in a different
language so i can't i can't listen to
this one
so um mmm dude it thunderstor
know sitting at this coffee shop because
that's what I do
and it started thundering I was
with my Irish friend and it just went
boom and we jumped and he looked at me
and he said if that happens again can
you hold me um
yeah man it was it was we don't
have that in LA like boom and the
lightning thunders I mean so Russian we
don't have that in LA like in LA the
boom lightning and the thunders sir
Russian um so yeah but uh oh by the way
um people are saying to me hey what's
your coup to mean I'm a baby tell me
what the you khuda means hey you're
not a baby if you don't know what if you
don't know if you're a cooter or not
you're not baby I mean you know you can
listen to my podcast but you're not be
hey by the way good thing it's
mmm
good thing it's it's been ten
minutes and it's already sweltering in
here because I turn the air off
oh cool New York hey New York thanks um
so yeah so I was at I was in Baltimore
and I have a question for everybody
actually and my friends disagree with me
and I understand I mean I think I might
be in the minority I think I am
can you put in public can you put your
feet up on another chair or like hang it
over the table or a couch because I do
that all the time because I'm a tall
drink of water man I sprawl I do that
Bon Jovi said you know what I mean
I air out my if I had a dude if I had a
I would be airing it out but I
don't have a and it's being aired
out but you know I'm talking about
I don't wear shorts so you can't see my
balls so it's fine only wear pants know
why cuz I'm over 11 so mm-hmm
so yeah man I'm uh I'm doing this in
Baltimore I'm in a mall it's got a
kiosk a Starbucks kiosk and I
flew in a day early so had nothing to do
I went to the mall got a Starbucks I put
my leg over the know burped
sorry that's a gross so gross
not directive um so I put my leg over
the um would he call it table and my
calf was over like the side corner or as
myrish but it would say the side corner
um of the sorry hold on lawyer of the
table and as it's over there this
security guard is like cleaning up near
me now by the way the table is a
mess no nobody's clean this table since
it's got crumbs and it's
got old muffins that Starbucks
discontinued like just like crumbs and
streaks of like
from a baby um and I got my calf
up hanging up on there this guy comes up
to me
mmm security guy with by the way had a
Mountie hat on hey this guy's a security
guard in the mall in Baltimore
why does he have a Mounties cap on hey
man take it off don't ever don't even
wear
had your security put on a shirt that
says security that's it you've got gun
don't wear a Mountie hat all right
he's a mall security in Baltimore
nonetheless so it's probably dealt with
a lot more than normal mall Security's
because it's Baltimore and I'm sure
people get stabbed in the face at the
mall but um she comes up to me I see him
coming out to me so I take my
leg off the table because people are
always telling me to take my leg
off the table shouldn't chairs and he
says hey man you can't put your leg up
on the table like that and then since I
already had taken it off I said oh yeah
it's not up and he said yeah but it was
up and I said huh so since it was and
it's not now I guess you don't have to
tell me that anymore huh what a
slammed them you know I mean I mean I
murder them in two sentences
that's it that's a wrap there's no more
to talk about so he got all bunched up
cuz he's a man and I'm a man too so it
was like a little bit of a
standoff you know uh so he said he was I
so I said yeah I doesn't have to you
have to tell me that cuz I already took
him down then right and he said yeah
well so of course even though the
conversation was over he said yeah well
hmm you know he says uh what'd he say he
said you can't um people have to eat
there so you can't be putting your feet
up like that and I said I looked at him
I said oh yeah and he said yeah and then
he walked away so that's my Baltimore
story I mean it's amazing though like
when well so anyway my question is do
you need to like can you not put
your feet up on it now I get it I get it
because all yeah it's appealing it's
disrespectful and but I think it's
like a case-by-case basis mmm I mean
obviously I'm not going to do it at a
um restaurant right that would be bad I
got my feet up on the tail but like
sometimes I'll have like my foot up on
the booth just chilling and the guy that
came he can't do that like what are you
talking and then they'll be like treat
it like your home this is what I do at
home it bothers me because this the
ground everything that's a serf I Got
News for you dude everything that's a
surface is layered and and I believe
this in actual okay layered in
layered literally in feces you're about
when you flush a toilet if you leave the
toilet ball open that particles fly
out like 30 feet from the toilet like
your whole bathroom is covered in
literal and then they get that on
their hands and then they touch
everything their everywhere feces
are covered everywhere you're walking on
the ground in New York you're kind of
ground Baltimore you think you think
just cuz it's on the ground it's not
also in your mouth whatever touches the
ground touches something else that
touches your mouth yeah you don't have
to be a CSI guy to know that
there's in our mouths literally so
I can hang my cap off the table that's
how I feel you know why cuz it's on
table also the tail wasn't even clean
take your Mountie hat off guess what
your Mountie hat has on it it's all
good but does hmm I also don't like
people who take their jobs to the next
level like that nothing was happening
dude you mall security right nothing was
happening so just chill do
nothing get paid to do nothing if that's
what's happening I've been hard
on the road uh because it's just lonely
I didn't have my openers until I got to
New York so in Baltimore I was
why they have 25 sports channels in
every hotel room its ESPN on espn2 espn3
ESPN Classic hey ESPN classics what dude
the game is over
hey the game is in the past sober you
know guys who are like don't tell me
what happened nothing with the score is
I want to watch the game I have a TiVoed
first of all to those guys by you CUDA
but this yes being classics I mean 15
times worse oh but but Ozzie Smith it
was when he by oh but you don't
understand Bobby Bonilla that was when
he by but this was the game when Michael
Jordan wore the jersey that by oh yeah
yeah but you don't get it because
yamir Jager scored three goals
on by hey yeah but uh uh-oh
that was when Don Mattingly oh
my
it's a classic game you know what
classic means over it's an over game but
it was when Ken Griffey senior oh really
by but John
akun by is his name Jean Mackin by
shouldn't watch a game hey if you're
watching John McEnroe play a tennis game
guess what you better be there alive
because he's not he's not televised
anymore and if you're watching a John
McEnroe game on TV it's on ESPN classics
and you killed her
all right you don't that's crazy man
I imagine these just fat fat
with mustaches just like hey this
was the game no this was the game
Carlton Fisk Conn Carl Yastrzemski this
was the game yeah that's just
ESPN classics is another another level
of high what are you doing that's like
the ultimate level of high what are you
doing
like I want to meet somebody doing that
and when they go like this I'm raw I'm
I'm you know I'm I'm Robert I want to go
hi what are you doing I'm Chris that
comes before I'm Chris cuz what are you
doing hi Chris are hey welcome to hey
welcome to the game show what are you
doing today our contestants are watching
ESPN Classic now they're watching a
show we're what's his
name john olerude or a regular hat at
first base not a helmet sports
nuts well know what I'm talking about
not supporting us I just I'm not a sport
nut I just remember what the
happened when I was watching TV when I
was watching guys throw a ball around
because I was 11 and once I got
12 I realized it's not really that fun
anymore
I get it I know my opener Mike
he always is like but this is
competition at its finest and this and
that yet I just don't care I don't have
that competitive bone in me I don't have
that if here's the thing I have it with
me I get competitive with myself but
dude like if I'm on a team and we lose
guess what is the other guy's fault
I'm not taking that blame you
should have passed it better
you should have ran around a
little faster right practice how you
should have done two-a-days and
scrimmaged harder me not my fault that's
why I like to do like martial
arts a little bit a little bit and I
like stand up it's it's always a
it's you you're competing with yourself
man didn't land and with my
trying to do a what do you call it
uh the more you know what do you call
those kind of words are just going man
I'm 37 and words are just going public
service announcement yeah I can still
sing it big you know I got my
voices all up um so yeah that's
just weird
ESPN classics uh-huh I watched so I just
flip and man this that's what the life
is meant um got my iced americano um
went to this hipster place and um what
do you call it the porno Lower East Side
you know it's a hipster place when a
bunch of Asians are around it or in it
you know nobody is hipper than a
Asian I swear to God they know what's up
eat one or two years before you know
what's up they'll be wearing a
like a boat on their head like a little
paper mache boat and you'll be like the
is that what the is that
Japanese guy doing what is that what
does that Korean guy doing and then a
year later you start seeing
popping up in New York LA
Seattle with paper mache little
boats on their heads and you're like
they were right Asians know what's up
when it comes to fashion dude you laugh
I laugh I still laugh even though it's
now
but they'll dude bro you think
you think like these
are on cutting edge like
it like the American designers and
even like the Italian designers nah
brother some Asian dude and like
it he's in North Korea even though
he's not allowed to do it but he's like
underground and he does it he's so
fashion-forward bro he's got a little
boat in his head a monocle and
wears like hats all around his body not
just like all hats like straw hats over
his dick and uh legs and his
shirt is made of hats and this guy
everyone's laughing in five
years then there's somebody in Japan
like in a village somewhere and he's
wearing like a little boat on
his head little paper mache boat he's
got two monocles and he's wearing
feathers from like some bird that he's
almost dead but he kept it alive he just
plucks the feathers out and he
pastes him to his body and everyone's
laughing even the North Korea guys
laughing at him but then he's like you
see you see and in ten years bro
ten years we're not gonna be the ones
laughing as well gonna be wearing
feathers with little boats on
our heads and to monocles and that guy
will die a hero and no one would
have known it because the knowledge is
so passed through like the game of
telephone that we don't even know what
the happened in him we weren't
over to created it we don't know we
don't know who created it mm-hmm
fashion-forward man my babies um fashion
is uh is wild in New York you know it's
out of control you see I saw a guy I
think I don't know sometimes I don't
know if a guy's super fashionable or
homeless I saw a guy with the I put it
on my Instagram story with like a metal
twisty around head piece I'll
know if he was fashion-forward refusing
in person he was sit on a stoop she's
probably crazy but maybe not he wasn't
Asian know some of you wasn't yeah
just talking to people um mmm I by the
way when I when I saw that guy um with
the with the metal hat
fashion-forward guy in New York um I was
in New York I was outside the Comedy
Cellar just hanging out I wasn't going
out because my voice mmm but I hear
commotion it's so weird how New York New
York is like it's so New York always it
you can go out for an hour and the most
New York thing will happen to you right
like like this
I was out we were outside the Comedy
Store or Comedy Cellar I was with my
opener one of my openers Irish and this
do I hear a commotion first
of all I see this dude walk by and I get
a weird feeling from him and I pay
attention to this because I think
that humans are capable of knowing when
some shits gonna go down before it goes
down because we can pick up cues and the
intuition woman's intuition that is
real dude
I believe that just who's walking around
I clocked him and I knew I was like this
guy something's up with this guy don't
even know why and you know what
you know why deep down in your head but
you don't know why you don't know how to
articulate you're like something's up
with that guy it's like in movies when
somebody's like I don't like this guy
and I don't know why but I don't like
him that shit's true she's walking by
walks by a register him he
leaves and I'm like iron whatever so I'm
talking to Irish for a little bit and
all of a sudden you're commotion
where that guy was walking man and then
outside of another club or
whatever and then I see that guy running
and another guy chase him like
you get smashed in
and then he gives up
because he was fat a little bit the
other guy was look spry so he ran away
the first guy that I saw and then I was
like oh well maybe I was right about
that he started
weird but I was like maybe wasn't
his fault and then I see the guy walked
back over with like he looked like it
looked like a level like a level with
with a bubble on it to see for
construction workers like a long one
with like um it was metal with like
taped up a taped up for it was taped up
so he could use it as a handle
and he's like where he was
gonna beat the out of this guy with
a level it's illegal and he'd never
shirt on at this point it was like so
insane and then oh and then the guy with
the tin the crazy metal hat was I think
before you do what you do man think
before you do what you do you're gonna
go right to jail like s in New York
measured me him from like Idaho and
visiting and that's the first thing you
see you black oh I didn't really
expect this stuff to happen the most New
York part about it was nobody really
gave a that I was going down hey
this in New York fashion babies here's
how you know fashion works because I
want to buy that supreme I don't
even get it
all that supreme that that brand
whatever that brand is with the hoodie
with the supreme logo on it that supreme
low anything with that supreme logo it
people are going to sleep over in front
of a supreme store the night before to
get it they put out a brick a brick with
the the supreme logo on it the brick and
they sold it and and people rely enough
to get that so literally that's the
joke like I mean I can't make it funnier
I can't be like yeah what if they
puts a premium on a blender and
then sold that that's not as funny as
they made a brick and sold it that's the
funniest part that's the funniest one
we're gonna say oh yeah what if they
sold dildos that's not as funny brick
I mean and people lined up to get it
talk about CUDA dude
but the branding they have is amazing
just that clean supreme I
want two supreme hoodie I want a
supreme hat I don't even wear hats one
supreme almost I wanted the supreme
um Pippins I didn't get them the
shoes uh because I felt like a chump you
know but yeah man they know mmm yeah
dude IIIi don't wait in line for
anything you know you don't have to if
you're in America you don't have to wait
in line there's a spot across
the street from the actually I
want to give out where but uh the in in
LA where they line up every day for
breakfast outside of the and and
I've been to the place and it's fine but
you're lining up to eat breakfast and
you're not in Russia in 1982 I don't
know if that analogy makes sense I think
probably they did that though in 1982 in
Russia but like come on man
what do you go to go to the place down
the street hey hey man hey I want to go
up to each of those people tab under him
and go to the place down the street
they got breakfast too excuse me ma'am
go to the place down the street
yeah excuse me you CUDA ma'am you'd be
an idiot you stay in here go to the
peasantry feed me sir and your kids your
kids I know you don't really have much
of a mind of your own cuz your kids but
your father and mother they're being
pieces of going down the
block go to a different place and go get
eggs wait 30 minutes in line to get a
breakfast when you don't have to
oh you live in the land of opportunity
don't do that I don't get it don't wait
in lines because you don't have to
unless you want to but then also realize
you being pieces shared it's free conch
but still
you feel me I know you fill me hmm Hilux
night after night two people lay in the
same bed but when it comes to but when
it comes time to buy a new mattress only
one gets their way until now introducing
Hilux sleep where you can buy a mattress
online customized for both of you for
hundreds of dollars instead of thousands
it's way cheaper than what you normally
see so you got to go to helix sleep calm
is a really great idea go to helix sleep
calm answer a few simple questions based
on four key preferences and the result
will be you know like custom it'll be
like a sleep profile that's used to
build you your most comfortable mattress
you'll ever sleep on helix they worked
with sleep scientist so it's not like
you know some guys are like I know how
to lay down they work with scientists
you know what that is that's official
they created a bed that is better than
any other mattress out there whether it
be in a store honestly or online so it
arrives at your door in about a week so
you're tired order it shows up you sleep
on it shipping is completely free go to
helix sleep calm / congrats and get $50
off your order
that's helix sleep calm / congrats to
get $50 off of your order helix sleep
calm / Congrats
hey guys you know what I'm wearing right
now me undies if you've been settling
for store bought underwear five packs
you don't do that this is going to
change your life this is so good don't
do those store bought 5 packs anymore
don't do that go to me on these and do
that me and ease calm / Congrats get 20%
off your first pair my undies are
designed in LA and that's where I live
so you know it's cool but they're from
sustainably sourced micro modal and
that's fabric that is three times softer
than cotton dude I got me on DS and I
gave it to my cousin I gave a three pair
of underwear
at a restaurant which is super weird to
give somebody hand somebody underwear in
a restaurant he Galen
he texted me later this is true he let
texted me later
this is them these are the most
comfortable things I've ever put on my
body and it is true it really happened
that's my cousin Jordan it happened you
can save time and money each month with
monthly subscription you're saving money
and time it's easy they send them to you
you're not ready for subscription it's
okay it still saved me undies is
offering you 20% off your first pair
just use special URL my undies comm /
congrats and get 20% off your first fare
go ahead and revamp your underwear
drawer
me Indies comm / congrats me on days
comm / Congrats
you know that's how we do it say yeah
New York New York air every time I come
to New York I feel like I'm gonna see
Riza and I met him but I always felt
like that even before I met him
New York air hagas guys you ever have a
ballpark be frank that's why I
feel like people gonna be saying in New
York no matter what you're walking down
the street hey hey I got a question for
you
you ever have a ballpark be frank
I feel like in New York don't miss a
hotdog you got a ballpark be
frank huh hey Dominick hey Dom you ever
have a ballpark be frank huh like
I mean I had a hot dog with me ballpark
before it's a thing
ah it's the same thing man you're
a ballpark be frank that right
there that's a that's something
put in a bunt you're putting your
mouth you chew it up you
eat it up you it out later
you buy a hotdog
you're a you might as well the
boob give a ballpark be frank I
give a
have a ballpark be frank if I
New York now I know if you're
going to act come up to me and ask me up
and talk to me about that tomorrow
because if
listen the podcast and walk by me and
say this but whatever hey yeah this
is the most New York thing I could
happen hey you ever ever ballpark
be frank and the other guy says get 2 3
times y 2 3 times a week at a
ballpark be frank I don't even go to
ballpark to do it I get
him i grill him on a outside go
to my place in Queens forget it
man forget about it I eat Bobby
Frank all day long book I Got
News for you the other day a seven
ball park beef franks
one day and let me tell you something
none when it comes to my Uncle Tony
Michael Tony one day swear to God sat
down watching me 14 ball park be
Franks right in front of me God is my
witness she Sam Lyon God is my
witness um yeah I want that to happen in
in the world okay so I can laugh mmm
my voice huh
how about that my voice is gone and I
understand that it's because I talk as a
career but now all I have to do is talk
still trying to get it better for these
Florida shows Square cash square
crash remember as I said in the
beginning is the best way to pay people
back friends family henchmen ghosts the
undead zombies penises you know what I
mean if they need money you give it to
any sanity co-workers anyone
you uh you said anyone receiving money
is totally fast and free and most famous
can be deposited directly into your bank
account in seconds download the square
cash app link your debit or debit your
debit or credit card select an amount to
send and type in a friend's phone number
or email address to complete a payment
they'll get a notification they just
receive money that's it that's what
happens no gimmicks Square cash is
better than all the other apps like it
it's not a social network nobody buy
now when you pay for your hookers and
you know
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now be secretive and cool
and use square cash you know NSA um yeah
so the thing let's see what made me
laugh you know what this is what I do
when I walk around town or if I'm on the
road I walk around a lot of times I
checked my messages on my phone you know
texting with buddies uh sometimes I'm
alone though and I've got nothing the
phone's charging I'm chilling I'm just
thinking as and I realize that I
used to do this way more before phones
and it was way easier to right stand up
because of it I would just start
thinking a and I thought of
something that made me laugh so hard I
laughed by myself all the time by the
way and I guess it looks crazy but
whatever um I left so hard thinking of a
guy like courting a girl uh and like
trying to get her to go out and she's
like I don't know you know whatever I'm
like seeing someone like okay and then a
few months later hey anyone hang out
she just doesn't respond maybe a few
months later hey want to hang out hey
what's up hey and then she disappears
and then like maybe this goes on for a
year she's at a party hey let's hang out
like alright fine I'll finally you know
sure right I'll give it a shot and then
the guys finally takes her out to dinner
or whatever the you know she has a
good time they kiss maybe they make out
in the car he lets her out good night
oh she was pleasantly surprised oh so
not that then they go out again like
three days later and she still kind of
gives him the runaround she's like I'm
busy let's reschedule and so like okay
so then like five days later they end up
going out takes her to dinner again and
conversation is great rare and a go get
back to his place start having sex right
and he's like and it feels and it feels
good for both of them it's great
and say her name is Diane whatever and
he's having sex with her and right
before he orgasms after uh after all the
year of trying hang out there and in
courting her for a few weeks
right before he has an orgasm he goes
like this ooh I'm done your head off so
cool I mean he that like lunatic
but like so funny like what would she do
like after that year of trying to hang
out and then him just ruining it in that
moment to be like oh well she's never
gonna hang out with him again what a
weird time to mock her right below right
before he hasn't hung as if he just goes
oh I'm doing it oh I'm so cool Wow like
what would she do she would be like oh
oh my god you are a piece of
and he would be um but that would
be so funny if someone did that and you
can't do it if it's like your girlfriend
it has to be the first time you have sex
with somebody that's what makes it funny
because like the audacity and the
uncomfortableness of it would
annihilate me I would like I'm laughing
I laugh did I started crying laughing
about it days ago and it didn't happen I
was alone um so yeah
I thought that would be so funny I'm
going to look at these hashtags here see
what's up again the game this game in
the system
congratulations pod sometimes if you
will give me good Oh somebody could you
see somebody got a tattoo of jakku de
what's-his-name Anthony Frank Cologne
unreal i retweeted it and i retweeted it
and i put it on my instagram if you
don't if you hadn't see it but guy got a
tattoo it said you could oh he came to
my atlantic city show my family came in
my atlantic city show a little bit after
so afterwards i went out into the
showroom and I saw them in there were
like two stragglers left security was
pushing them out I think I was like we
got you CUDA tattoos bro and I was like
okay cool man and I thought he's just
around
then he tweeted the show was lit or
whatever check out the tattoos we got
which we were serious and I was like
what the it says your kuda on his
wrist I don't know getting funny tattoos
is weird to me like get it if you're
gonna get a tattoo it's badass just go
with that you know how like steve-o has
your name the words your name tattooed
on his ass um yeah that's not to me
that's like insane that's so weird I
know that's the point but uh this is a
good idea Paul Pablo at Paul underscore
Jay underscore Jimenez good name when do
we get matching outfits and you know do
some culty
you know here's some here's what I want
and this is actually a um something
that's I'm not around about this
I always thought it was cool when
couples dressed alike I think that
that's ball and for real and and
if you have family dress them like to it
whenever if I have a family or whatever
it is a wife and two kids you best
and believe we're all dressing the same
for a few a few of the days in the world
you know not every day that we've very
weird we're not all dentists but like or
like surgeons
but like no there's no doubt 100% we're
absolutely doing that red shirt red
pants like monochromatic - people are
gonna be like what what's with that red
family it's on with my family if I have
kids and a wife it's on the
cloak clothing-wise thematically it's on
you get a Tweety Bird shirt guess guess
who's got the Tweety Bird shirt -
daddy's got it - ok little Tommy excuse
me
Samantha my little daughter put on this
goddamn Tweety Bird shirt because
Tommy's wearing it and I'm
wearing it - and your wife and your
mom is wearing it - my wife oh
her name is um Yolanda of course my
wife's name will be Yolanda but yeah
Yolanda get the Tweety Bird shirts come
on bring them down but I don't want to
bring him down I ain't wearing
that Tweety Bird shirts no more bring
him down your lunder and I'm
coming up and get them and I know you
don't want me to come up and get them
fine mmm that's how it's gonna be
living with me dude it's not it does not
cult that's family bro
that's family um thoughts on DJ Khaled
getting booed off stage at EDC I didn't
know that happens Stevens a Zaharias at
Steve bruh hmm
I didn't know that happen but uh
EDC how about that
all right I can't stand people that just
think they need to get tickets to
everything I have people I see
like that it's just like neck you got
booed off stage how about getting booed
off stage at the worst place is that
good or bad on even now I'm sure I'd get
booed off stage at EDC um yeah that'd be
real bad um that'd be really uh bad
getting booed off stage is horrible I
don't think I've ever been booed off
stage No um but yeah
Aaron Brown at Aaron J Brown please talk
to us babies about writing man on fire
and how your act developed give the
coudé is a little nibble I already
mentioned that in one of the past uh
that says Aaron Brown I already
mentioned that in one of the past
episodes I don't know which one but uh
yeah
so go listen to that one if somebody
could have them out tweetment I don't
know which one it was um so anyway um
yeah but that man on fire comes out very
soon
and it's exciting that was like
two years in the making I think last one
was in April 2014 in his 2017 now so I
can't believe I have actually new
material since then mmm that I'm trying
to do it with but uh I don't know I kind
of want to wear no shirt on a special
and be like the ja rule of comedy all
the way I think Bert Kreischer did that
nevermind can't do that
well I mean you could do it also does
cool Bert did that though mmm he's
funny as um that guy's so
funny actually even like in real life
he's just a great storyteller
um so yeah um all right well what else I
don't know I'm gonna maybe wrap this up
because my voice is killing me
and I got to save West Palm Beach but
that's West Palm Beach I will be there
soon I can't wait to get some
rays catch some rays to it I'm going to
go get some I'm gonna get a wood bathing
suit because I never pack one so I'm
just going to buy another one so this
time when I bring it home I'll have 40
bathing suits instead of 30 - did I have
so many bathing suits because I always
buy them on the road mm-hmm like some
idiot the rain stopped in New York I'm
happy about a man I Love New York I'm
gonna go eat myself a ballpark be
frank I feel like whenever my voice is
like really really really scratchy that
I I'm I feel like I'm John Malkovich and
in the line of fire
um I don't remember what he says but I
just feel like this is how he called
when he used to call Clint Eastwood need
to sound like this talking to him I'm
going to kill the president mr.
Jack his name name was boom gee I wonder
if the it was definitely Jack
clinic his name was Jack for sure and in
a lot of fire they should name more lead
guys Jack in movies because that's not
that's not like how many jack
reacher Jack Ryan and all of them and
all the other ones honor
Schwarzenegger's played Jack hey Arnold
Schwarzenegger is not named Jack
obviously I think we talked about this
in the 10-minute podcast before yeah so
I don't know you know what I was
surprised about this week actually was
when Cosby got let off first of all when
he got let off man convicted someone's
hard huh like everything needs
to be the deck the deck needs to be
stacked because they can't try they know
obviously the guy did it because
80 women said he did it and have can
recount specific stories I don't exactly
I'm not convinced it's the Illuminati
that's two going after him you know but
like you have to it has to be on
that one case like they can't take any
of the outside cases and or the
you know the pending and have a
cloud the juries in this case so I guess
they felt they didn't have proof which
is sounds crazy um but then when
the lawyer wouldn't cause his lawyer
afterwards had that press conference and
he said mr. Cosby now has his power back
I mean is there a worse
way to say that after beating a rape
case he has his power back first of all
he's not he man second of all I mean
that's what you used to rape is your
power over women physically and then for
him to be like yeah mr. Cosby's power is
bad his power back he said like four
times I don't say that
have a better bedside manner he might as
well walked out on me like we want
we want
Cosby's power is back his power is
back drink that Bill Cosby gives
you like hey man just Don say Don say
hey man Don say that was crazy when they
said when the guy said that my jaw
dropped
I was like did this world we
live in as a joke told you it um but
whatever I'm a comedian so at
least I my is all a joke and it's
supposed to be yes I don't know I got to
take care of my voice you guys thanks
for listening um you guys I really
appreciate you listening closing
statements Square cash is the best way
to pay people back make sure to do that
download square cash app for iOS or
Android now I got my upcoming show dates
tweet me at hashtag congratulations pot
and also there's merchandise those
shirts
there's congratulations podcast shirts
on my website at Chris D'Elia calm so go
there support the podcast we're on it's
got those cool emojis and the artwork
rate and review the show iTunes Google
Play and stitcher
and then man on fire is coming out next
Thursday I'm sorry next Tuesday on the
27th at like midnight or whatever watch
it
tweet about it share this podcast with
your friends have a muhfucka Ralph you
guys thank you for listening my babies
one